hey you guys time once again for my
movie review show flickers of fear now a
couple weeks back probably two or three
weeks ago i reviewed a monster movie
korean monster movie called the host
from 2006 which was directed by bong
joon ho who as i said was kind of you
know people that were into horror movies
or indie movies or asian films uh knew
his name obviously because he's done a
bunch of films but he came to sort of
worldwide acclaim after winning the
oscar
in 2019 i believe it was or 2020 for
parasite which is indeed a brilliant
film now when i did the review for the
host somebody in the comments said oh
you should totally do a review of
memories of murder uh the movie that he
made before the host in 2003 and i had
seen it previously and had been wanting
to get around to it so i said i
absolutely will do that and then i
noticed that it was on hulu so i figured
might as well do it sooner rather than
later because i had been wanting to
rewatch it anyway
so this was bong joon ho's second film
uh as i said it came out in 2003 his
first one was called barking dogs never
bite which i still haven't seen yet
although i think shutter might have it
but so this movie is actually based on a
true story loosely well actually not
really all that loosely the case that it
was based on i can't remember i think we
might have done an episode about it
either that or i wrote about it in one
of my faceless villain books maybe both
it's possible i did both because the the
details of it were very very uh familiar
to me
this is based on
what is essentially uh you know korea's
first set of serial murders the hwasyong
uh murders
and they took place from 1986 to 1991 so
this film is like a dramatization of
that although it's sort of
it's not necessarily like a
straightforward police procedural
because at the time that the movie this
came out the time the movie came out uh
the person who was responsible for these
crimes had not been caught and nobody
knew who he was he was actually caught
later on i'll get into that in the end
because i actually didn't know this
until i was like re-watching this movie
but yeah he has been uh caught now
so in this movie as i said it's sort of
like i've seen it compared a lot to
david fincher zodiac in the sense that
it's a movie that was based on a real
case that was unsolved and so it was
left sort of open-ended and it had to
concentrate more on the investigation
and on
the effects on the people that were you
know investigating the case and that's
kind of what this one does too although
this one takes a slightly different
approach i feel like
so what you have
you have two detectives detective park
who is kind of like
it's this very small town where these
murders first start happening like the
first murder that they find it's this
woman and she's been you know bound and
gagged she's been raped and strangled
and
you know you're led to believe this is a
very small town this is something that
doesn't happen
or has never happened before and the
local police force seemed very
ill-equipped to deal with it now as i
said the first part of this film is set
in 1986 because that's when the first of
the murders uh was discovered
so this sort of small town uh you know
and it's very funny like even at the
beginning it almost has an element
i don't wanna i don't wanna like
oversell this too much but it almost has
an
element of black comedy to it just in
the way
that the police force are so
inept because they're just completely
out of their depth you can tell and the
methods that they have for solving
things they seem like they don't take it
all that seriously and it's it's not
really played for laughs but it is kind
of like sadly
i mean he is definitely making like a
satirical commentary about this time
period in korean law enforcement and
obviously you know this small town they
didn't have all the forensic
investigation techniques that we have
nowadays uh but just so much that like i
said they you know they'd never seen a
serial killer before nothing of this
magnitude and they really had no idea
what they were doing
so you know the first crime scene like
you can tell right out of the gate that
these cops just have no idea what
they're doing it's like they're running
all over the crime scene they're not
taking pictures everyone's just kind of
doing their own thing and not
you know cordoning anything off or
anything like that they find a footprint
which they presume is from the killer up
on the road but then like a guy in a
tractor happens to drive by and runs it
over so they don't get you know any uh
evidence from that
so
you have these so they have these two
main investigators that are working on
it detective park is seems like this
sort of like laid back he's very much
a gut instinct small town kind of guy
he's like you know you don't know all
the locals around here you know
things like that and he's very much
one of those people he he says that he
has a shaman eyes in that he can just
like look into someone's eyes and know
whether they're guilty or not he's also
very kind of like superstitious which
you get into later on and he's partnered
with this guy cho
who basically his whole
his whole uh investigative technique is
just well we'll find somebody that we
think did it and then we'll just beat
the crap out of them until they confess
to it and then
one and done you know what i mean so and
uh you know park is a little bit like
that too like nobody really seems to
have that much of a problem with beating
confessions out of people like
it's not really seen as anything that's
that unusual
so you have these two guys
uh there's a couple of murders so they
find one and then they find another one
like not too long later at which point
uh another detective is sent from seoul
you know the big city to help them out
because obviously they're just kind of
like they have no idea what they're
doing and this is something that has
never been seen before
so the funny thing is too is that as
soon as the detective from seoul comes
in uh detective ceo
he's walking into town and he asks this
like there's this woman also walking and
she as you would like thinks he's the
killer because like i said there's a big
panic in the town now because two women
have turned up dead so she thinks this
dude is following her and like freaks
out and he's like no no i'm just asking
for directions and she wigs out falls
into a ditch and then he goes down there
he's like seriously i'm not it's like
you know what i you know and then like
the other cops come and like beat the
crap out of him he's like no no i'm a
detective like i came from seoul so you
know what i mean so it's that kind of
thing
so as soon as uh detective co arrives
there is immediately a conflict like i
said he's a big city guy these other two
are kind of like we know all the locals
we we're gonna know the person when we
pick them up just by looking at them or
we're just gonna beat the crap out of
them and then it'll they'll solve
everything whereas co is very much uh
you know more like a modern investigator
would be in the sense that he's very
science-based like no we need evidence
um you know we can't just go around
beating the crap out of people and you
know we have to do everything correctly
and get some actual evidence
what actually ends up happening is that
they pick up
the first suspect they pick up is like
this mentally challenged uh kid they
keep calling him a boy but he doesn't
really look that young i'm not really
sure how young he's supposed to be um
but they pick him up
and
they question him
and you can tell i mean he's clearly
like not all there you know what i mean
um and he does seem to know some details
about the crime like when they
interrogate him but the you know the
detectives are also asking him like
really leading questions and they
basically keep him for like three or
four days or something like that without
charging him and because he's you know
handicapped he can't really
you know protest about or anything like
that like his dad comes to protest but
there's not really much he can do about
it uh they also kind of you know rough
him up and [ __ ] like that as well now
they do kind of take him to the to the
crime scene and he does seem to know a
lot about it
but he keeps saying that it's like it
was a dream right
so they're convinced well this is the
guy uh you know this is the killer he
had was seen like following around like
one of the one of the first victims and
so it's got to be him all we need to do
is just beat the crap out of him until
he confesses to it problem being though
that one thing that co notices is that
uh is that this suspect has kind of like
webbed fingers
and he said well this person could
obviously not have done these murders
because the knots that were tied like to
strangle the women and like many of them
were left with like girdles or underwear
or whatever like uh on their faces were
like knotted up and hog tied and he said
the knots in there were very complicated
and it's like somebody with webbed
fingers would not have been able to uh
pull that off so this can't be the guy
so
park and chow were very upset by this
because i guess they were having a good
time like beating the crap out of this
mentally challenged man uh so they had
to let him go
but one thing ceo figures out is that
there have been two murders but he says
no there's gotta be a third one because
this uh woman that lived around here she
went missing like two months ago and we
haven't found her body yet
um so
i'm sure there's three victims at this
point and he does turn out to be right
he also notices a couple of other
connections that the dumbass detectives
have not noticed in that the murders
always take place uh on rainy nights and
the first at least the first two or
three victims were wearing red
so he does notice that connection so so
at this point so they have to let the
the first suspect go
another thing that's really interesting
about this movie is that there's also a
female detective and she's actually used
as a decoy at one point like she puts on
a red dress and she walks like through
the streets like on a rainy night by
herself like hoping to bait the killer
but it turns out the killer uh kills
someone else that night
but the thing about it and i guess this
is set in 1986 and it's also kind of
making like a little bit of a satirical
jab
at
these
you know bumbling male detectives who
are very i mean they're very very like
uh overtly like hyper masculine
everything is like gut instinct they
almost kind of like think it's maybe
i don't want to say i don't want to go
so far as to say they maybe think it's
like effeminate to like follow the book
or follow the rules or you know use
science like to solve crimes they're
just like no it's all about gut and like
beating the crap out of people but the
female detective actually comes up with
like another really good connection
saying you know every night that the you
know i listen to this radio program at
night and every night that the killer
has struck they played this particular
song which is like a kind of a rare song
they don't usually play it otherwise
it's called the sad letter it's like and
they always say that somebody requested
it like they sent in a postcard and
request it so she's like maybe we should
call the radio station and see who sent
that postcard because the postcard says
something like you know play this song
on a rainy night or something like that
which seems super suspicious so she says
that like to the chief and ceo and
they're like oh [ __ ] that's like a good
idea whereas the two whereas park and
chair were just like that's the
stupidest [ __ ] thing i've ever heard
and everything like that and their whole
thing is well because we never found any
pubic hairs at any of the you know rape
and murder scenes that must mean
that the killer doesn't have any pubic
hair so they go off on this so they're
thinking maybe it's a monk or you know
park at one point goes to this like
sauna is like looking at everybody's
trunk and stuff like that these dudes
are like kind of idiots you know what i
mean and there's another thing too where
like at the next point like when they're
looking for another suspect so they do
that but it turns out that the radio
station has thrown the postcard away so
they have to kind of keep going back and
like you know hope that another postcard
comes in and they can find out where the
postcard came from now at this point
because park is so frustrated
he goes to essentially a shaman who
sells him this little scroll is like
yeah you have to go out to like the last
crime scene and do this like elaborate
like paranormal ritual and you pour this
stuff on there and it'll show you the
face of the killer it's just like
ridiculous so him and joe actually
believe this is gonna work and they
actually go out to the crime scene to to
do it um and it turns out too that co
has had the same idea not about doing
the the shaman spell or anything but he
wants to go back out to the crime scene
to see if the killer's gonna return now
while both of them are out there like
they're kind of on either side of this
road
like with these little kind of like
woods and everything this guy actually
does come walking into the woods and
he's acting like super super suspicious
like he pulls out like this woman's you
know panties and bra and he puts him
down the ground like organizes them and
then like he pulls his own pants down
and he has like women's like red
underwear on and so he starts like
jerking it so they're like well this is
obviously got to be the killer i mean
that's super super fishy so they all
kind of like jump and converge and the
dude runs away
now they end up finding him like he runs
and runs and there's like a big long
chase and he runs into this like
building site where there's you know
hundreds of dudes that are dressed in
the same kind of clothes that he had but
they do actually find him when he like
leans over and they see the back of his
red underwear so they bring him in and
it turns out that maybe and like i said
because the real crime had not been
solved at the time that this movie was
made you're not gonna find out who the
killer is it's not that kind of like
murder mystery so don't think that it's
gonna be like all solved at the end like
a hollywood mystery thriller because
it's not um it's left completely
ambiguous maybe one of the suspects they
picked up actually was the killer maybe
not like you don't really know and they
didn't know the movie is kind of like
it's not really about that it's kind of
like about sort of like the clash
between the different styles of
investigation uh the personalities and
also kind of how the frustration of the
investigation like uh changed people
into maybe you know something that they
uh
are not all that happy about so we'll
get into that too
uh so they bring this guy in
and it seems that this guy is probably
not the killer uh in the sense that
everyone thinks he's lovely and he's
like basically i just have a weird
fetish
about the crimes and it's like reading
about them kind of turned me on he's
like i know it's messed up but he's like
so i wanted to go out to the crime scene
and like kind of relive it he's like i
didn't do it but
uh so they have to let that guy go
because as it turns out co is off doing
some other investigation like he heard
this story from these two school girls
about like this weird person that like
lived by the bathrooms like out behind
the school and he goes to check that
lead out
and when he's there like he runs into
this woman and she says you know there's
this other woman that lives up there by
herself like you know on the hill like
overlooking the school and it's like
she's just like up there crying all the
time and it seemed like super strange so
you might want to check that out so he
goes and interviews that woman and it
turns out that she was attacked by
you're led to believe the same killer
but she survived
and she didn't see his face but she says
to him
she says but i do remember like that his
hands were really really soft like a
woman's hands so when ceo comes back and
they're interrogating you know the woods
masturbator guy like the red panties guy
theo looks at that dude's hands and
they're all like rough and [ __ ] up
he's like this guy's gonna just you know
cut him down because they were hanging
him upside down from the ceiling like i
said they're essentially like torturing
these uh suspects into confessing and
and they'll do it for a long time until
the people just like yeah whatever just
i just want to go home i'll sign
whatever you want uh so yeah so he's
like well this isn't him you know i had
a victim and it's you know she says that
the hands were soft
now they also find like a couple of the
newer it seems like the killer is
escalating because some of the latest
victims like have things uh inserted
into their vaginas like one of them has
like pieces of peach in there and then
like one of the later on ones has kind
of like cutlery like a knife and fork
and stuff like that like crammed up in
there so that's like pretty [ __ ] up
now eventually the radio station lead
does pan out and they are able to find
one of the postcards requesting that
weird song the sad letter and they find
an address so they go and find this dude
and this dude is named park uh hyun gu
and he works in a factory but he works
in the office and he has super super
soft hands
so they bring him in the way they
question him like i said it's left very
ambiguous as to whether this is the
killer or not so there's kind of like a
big confrontation at this point where
cho who like i said is the guy that just
wants to like beat everyone's ass until
they confess they're so sure that they
finally got him because this is the guy
that supposedly sent the postcards and
it seemed too much of a coincidence that
the postcards asked to play this
particular song on nights that it was
raining and those indeed were all the
nights that the killer uh you know
struck
then they're just like well all we have
to do is just again beat the crap out of
him
you know until he uh confesses
now
that doesn't really work out i mean he's
kind of like
very stoic and he's just kind of like no
it wasn't me and you know he's acting
kind of sketch but
like i said it could go either way
and at this point ceo and park park has
kind of come detective park has kind of
come to the conclusion he's like maybe
this whole beating people up is like not
really working out because he's had a
couple of things where his shaman vision
like where he's just looking and like
determining if people are guilty he's
kind of come to the realization that
that's not really working out for him
you know what i mean so he actually does
like grow somewhat and he's starting to
come more over to ceo's side like maybe
we need more scientific evidence and
then they go back to the first suspect
that they had like the mentally
challenged boy
and they and you know uh ceo was like i
thought you had just like coached him
into those answers and park was like no
i didn't
but then they figure out they're like
well he acted like he didn't he said he
didn't do it like but he kept saying it
was a dream they're like but you know
what maybe he saw it that's why he
remembered it so well so they actually
try to go and find that kid again and
when they go there it's like cho
who has been reprimanded for beating the
crap out of yet another suspect he
starts that he's drunk in this
restaurant where uh where the suspect's
dad runs it
and uh he just gets [ __ ] ragey and he
starts like beating the crab he smashes
the tv and starts beating the crap out
it just causes this big [ __ ] riot
essentially uh at which point the
suspect like uh you know comes in and he
starts hitting cho because you know for
revenge i guess because they beat the
[ __ ] out of him and ends up like hitting
him in the leg like with a stick but it
has like a big long nail at the end so
it like punctures his leg
um so at this point like park and ceo
are just kind of like man [ __ ] him he's
drunk and he's just beating the crap out
of everybody so they run after the
suspect
and uh obviously the suspect is uh you
know whose name is bayek i think and he
is completely terrified uh
understandably because these cops beat
the crap out of him for many days like
to try to get him to confess to
something that he probably didn't do
and so they're like no no we don't want
to like arrest you or anything we're
just going to say you know the murders
did you see them
and then you know he says yeah i saw him
and i saw the killer he's like i saw it
was raining that night and i saw his
face he's like three times because the
lightning kept lightning lighting up his
face so i saw what he looked like
and at this point uh ceo has a picture
of the latest suspect that they have
hyun gu and he pretty much like shoves
it into this kid's face and was like is
this him is this him and at which point
like bayek is like just starts like
wigging it and losing it and doesn't
really
identify him uh he just starts talking
about his scarred face and how maybe it
was his dad threw him in a fire and it
was this whole other thing and then he
runs off and he ends up getting hit by a
train like accidentally because they're
chasing him and so there goes their only
witness who saw what the killer actually
looked like it turns out too that cho
who got hit in the leg with the nail
uh he didn't go to the hospital right
away even though everyone told him to
and it turns out he got tetanus and
they're gonna have to like amputate his
leg so there's that uh so that's kind of
like it it's almost kind of like he got
those were like his just desserts i
guess for thinking that he could solve
everything with violence and it ended up
costing him his leg below the knee
meanwhile uh one of the investigators
like the forensic team as i said this is
19 you know this is 1986 to 1991 so they
didn't really have very good dna
technology
but they have discovered that one of the
bodies has some semen like on the
clothing
and at the time in korea they didn't
have the technology to uh you know do a
dna profile so they said we're gonna
have to send it to america in the real
case they actually did have to send it
they sent it to japan but you know in
the movie i guess like for a longer
thing so we have to send it to america
to get the dna results meanwhile this
latest uh suspect hyung gyu they are so
convinced that this is who it is because
he was the guy that uh you know sent the
postcards and he's like super fishy
they're like okay well we have to wait
until the dna comes back when the dna
comes back it'll prove that it's him and
we'll have solved the case but meanwhile
we have to let him go so we have to just
like follow him so they put like a 24 7
tail on him
so sadly though co is watching him one
night like he's at a little cafe or
whatever
and uh ceo who has been i mean
presumably these cops have been like
frustrated like working on this case
forever and it's just it's just dead end
after dead end and they're just getting
so they're getting to the point where
ceo is just kind of like maybe we should
just beat the crap out of him you know
what i mean so he's more coming around
to
violence just because he's so frustrated
that he can't solve it
so he actually ends up falling asleep in
his car on the watch when he wakes up he
sees that the suspect uh hyung-gu has
got on a bus and his car won't start he
can't you know follow him and he's just
like [ __ ]
so he tries to figure out where the guy
went it's raining that night uh they
hear like the song of the radio and
they're like holy [ __ ] like something's
gonna happen
and uh it does end up that even though
you don't know if young you did it you
just see him like on the bus he doesn't
get off by his house they don't like
know where he got off
and uh another girl does get killed that
night and it turns out to be one of the
school girls that cia was talking to
earlier like in
regards to the bathroom behind the
school
she ends up getting murdered
and at this point uh ceo has lost it
because he's this is a victim he knows
her he has talked to her in the course
of the investigation she's you know
still a school girl and he just like
loses any civility or any kind of like
sop to scientific evidence that he had
he's like i just want to kill this
[ __ ] because i'm sure that it's
him and that's how it's to go
so he basically like goes and there's
this really great scene like toward the
end of the movie where he goes and just
like threat he's like look i'm just
going to shoot you just tell me that
just tell me that you did it i want to
look in your face and he and you know
the suspect is just like kind of looking
at him and he's like yeah i killed him
all he's like that's what you want to
hear isn't it
and then it turns out that like as he's
beating the crap out of this dude like
on a you know railroad track or whatever
park runs up and said hey we got the dna
result
so they open the envelope right there
like while the dude is right there
handcuffed and the dna results are
inconclusive meaning it's probably not
that guy but it still maybe could be
because i guess it wasn't big enough
sample but like i said they couldn't
determine like whether this was it or
not and at this point again like ceo
just loses he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't need the documents and that's
kind of like going back to what he said
earlier it's like documents don't lie so
he was very much by the book very much
we need solid evidence and now he's just
like [ __ ] it i don't care what that says
i know that you did it and i'm just
gonna [ __ ] kill you like right now so
he just throws the paper away and is
basically gonna shoot the guy
uh but actually park steps in and stops
him again so it's almost kind of like a
complete role reversal these two like
park was the guy that was all gut before
he's like yeah we just need to look at
people's eyes we can figure out if
they're guilty and stuff and he actually
does that he like looks at the dude for
like a really long time
and then he
realizes he's like i can't tell i can't
tell if this person is guilty or not
so then uh basically he gets away like
uh ceo shoots at him but misses
so he just runs away like through the
thing and they let him go
and then we jump ahead to 2003 which was
contemporaneous when the movie was made
and park has quit the force uh which was
what his girlfriend wanted him to do
she's like look this kind of [ __ ] is
killing you um you know this isn't great
you probably shouldn't do this anymore
so he's quit and now he's kind of like a
salesman so he goes around you know
selling it's kind of like a juicer type
situation and uh he's married his
girlfriend they have a couple of kids
you know it's been several years
and while he's out on a run with uh you
know with some of his products he sees
uh the kind of road or the area where
the first body was found way back in
1986 so he tells the driver he's like
stop i kind of want to you know look and
like you know check it out
so he goes over there like it's sort of
like this culvert type thing like a like
a ditch with a little concrete thing
over it
and see he goes over there and kind of
like leans down and looks in there and
obviously there's nothing in there
because a long time ago
while he's leaning down to look at this
little girl this little school girl
walks by she's like wait you know what
are you doing mister and uh he says i
was just you know looking in here and
she's like is there anything in there
he's like no nothing
she's like that's really weird because
not because a little while ago there was
another guy here looking into that
culvert she said and i asked him the
same question like what are you doing
why are you looking in there and she
says he told me that he did something
there a long time ago and he just wanted
to like check it out
at this point park realizes that must
have been the killer like this many
years later revisiting the scene of the
crime
so even though he's not a cop anymore
like he asked the little girl what she
looked like what did he look like and
she's like well she's like he just
looked plain she's like ordinary like
there was nothing
about him that was like particularly
notable
and at this point there's a great ending
shot where park basically just like
looks right into the camera and just
like stares
and
me there's a couple different
interpretations of this final scene but
i think that uh that bong jin how
actually meant this he's using his
shaman eyes particularly to look out
into the audience because if you
remember at the time that this movie was
made the serial killer in uh huasiang
had not been caught so it's very
possible because this movie was
massively popular in korea you know and
millions of people saw it it's very
possible that the killer saw it too
and that park was staring into the eyes
of the killer you know trying to find
out who it was
so as i said this movie
it's if you're looking for kind of like
a standard like i said hollywood style
mystery thriller where everything is
solved at the end that's not what you're
gonna get this is much more even though
it's not exactly the same but it does
have some parallels with david fincher's
zodiac in the sense that it's based on a
real case that was unsolved and so it's
mostly focusing on like
other thematic elements rather than the
solution of the mystery so a lot so some
people if you kind of like a cut and
dried sort of narrative then this might
just frustrate you because it's just you
know it's dead end after dead it's much
more like a real police investigation
where you have this lead and it's like
oh this seems really promising and then
it turns out to fizzle out or it doesn't
really go anywhere or you know things
are just left hanging because that's
kind of what reality is like but in that
sense i think this is actually
one of the most brilliant
uh detective thriller mystery movies
ever made because of that because of its
realism
so the real case as i mentioned that
that this was based on uh happened in
hwasyong between 1986 and 1991 we might
have covered it on the show and or i
might have covered it in one of my
faceless villain books um it was 10
women
that were killed in the area pretty much
in the way that you see in the film and
for a long time the killer uh was not
caught
and there had been uh i believe there
was a play like written about it i think
called come to see me and the guy that
wrote that like the play right behind
that like helped bong jin ho like write
the screenplay for this so they kind of
collaborated on that as well
and uh so essentially what ended up
happening was that dna actually did end
up catching the person that did this
many years later in 2019
they actually matched the dna
on some of the vic on one of the victims
i believe to a dude named lee choon jay
or jai
uh who was in his 50s at the time that
they caught him
and he was actually imprisoned for
something else he was actually
imprisoned for raping and murdering his
sister-in-law
uh in busan so he was already serving a
life sentence in prison but they ended
up matching his dna to some of the
victims of the huasiang serial killer
case although he initially denied
involvement later on he did actually
confess to 14 murders including the 10
having to do with the hwasong uh serial
killer case he couldn't be tried in a
lot of those because korea has a statute
of limitations on murder
which is crazy because we don't but uh
so most of the cases had you know the
statute of limitations had run out so he
couldn't be charged for those but he was
already in uh prison for
another murder that he had done that
didn't have anything to do with those
but he did eventually confess to those
so they actually have caught him now
so that's what's kind of interesting too
is that uh bong joon ho said that one of
the things that spurred him to make this
film initially like when the killer had
not been caught yet was that he was very
curious to like look into this person's
face that's kind of why the whole shaman
eyes thing like came about
and so i so i thought it was interesting
i'm like well now you can you can go on
the wikipedia page and you can look at
the dude's face and indeed he does just
look like a very ordinary human being as
many serial killers do which is what is
so scary about them so yeah uh if you
really liked any of bong jin ho's other
films like i said if you like the host
if you liked parasite which i kind of
feel like are probably his best known
ones or his most widely seen ones um
definitely go back and give this one a
watch especially if you like kind of not
necessarily police procedurals mystery
thrillers types if you like zodiac if
you like something like that that's sort
of based on a true story then i think
this will really really be right up your
alley it's as i said it almost has like
a strange like dark comedy element to it
at least in the beginning just because
it's sort of make like poking satirical
fun
at how
uh bumbling the cops were how out of
their depth they were like dealing with
this magnitude of crime um and back in
the 80s they didn't have all the
forensic technology and they didn't
really know what they were doing they
didn't seem to take it all that
seriously and so it's kind of making
it's kind of using the black comedy in
service to that satire
so it's kind of like that but it's
definitely one of the best korean films
ever made this one and i saw the devil
are probably
two of my favorite korean films ever
they're completely different but i mean
this one is just it it's just brilliant
every single
thing about it is brilliant like all of
the you know interactions between the
characters the clash between the
different investigative styles the way
that uh this frustration with the case
is frustration that it's not going
anywhere and he's just you know ceo in
particular who started out as this very
by-the-book scientific evidence type of
guy and then he gets to a point too
where he's just so
frustrated and beaten down by this the
lack of progress that he just turns into
his own worst enemy like he starts you
know being violent just like the other
ones even though he knows that that
doesn't work and he just lets his
frustration and emotion get the better
of him it's just a really good
examination of the personalities behind
that and what that type of investigative
work might do to you to your moral
compass for example but yeah this is if
you have hulu it's actually on hulu at
the moment i'm sure you can probably
stream at other places as well but
i mean anything if you like anything
like this like murder mysteries south
korean films anything like that and you
haven't seen it then you really do
need to owe yourself to see it because
it's a great great film and it's just i
love it and i really really loved like
uh getting to revisit it so that will do
it for this flickers of fear i will see
you guys on the next one bye